man in charge of America's drug war he
made history when he was announced the
first physician ever to serve in that role it
comes at a time when this country is battling an
extraordinary crisis and American dies every five
minutes by overdose on this broadcast we've gone
inside prisons and to our Southern border to see
what's happening this week we went to Washington
the estimate is that the overdose crisis costs
us 1.5 trillion a year which is equal to the GDP
of Russia correct so we're losing that amount of
money Raul Gupta was born in India but raised in
Maryland as a doctor he's seen addiction patients
recover and he's attended funerals of those who
did not after running West Virginia's public
health Bureau and working for the March of Dimes
he became director of The Office of national
drug policy control you're the first physician
to serve in this role what message do you hope
that sends well I know that the Methodist census
that this is a public health crisis that the
nation is in doing as Gupta told us gone are
the days when the root of the drug Scourge was
found in poppy fields and on farms today it's
a chemical World especially when it comes to
fentanyl something President Biden discussed
this week at a summit of North American leaders in
Mexico today we've discussed how all three of us
can continue to deepen and strengthen our shared
efforts to cut off the flow of illegal fentanyl
including by tackling the precursor chemicals used
in synthetic drugs so many of these precursors are
for fentanyl are coming from China why can't more
be done to limit the amount coming in from China
well that's exactly what we're doing from day one
it's it's still coming in though a lot well what
we want to do is make sure that we are working
with the People's Republic of China or PRC uh to
make sure that they are holding accountable the
Bad actors within China that are shipping but we
also want to make sure that we know what's coming
in before it gets here that is not happening to a
level that it's acceptable to me at this point and
that's exactly why we're continuing to push them
to do more it's the bigger problem the Bad actors
in China who are selling the precursors or is it
the the drug dealers and the cartels in Mexico
who are using those precursors to manufacture
I think Jeff what you just highlighted is the
global imprint of this problem but Gupta says
he's focused not just on Supply but demand and
what's called harm reduction that means not
waiting until people ask for help but instead
bringing it to them we meet them where they
are as opposed to expecting them and I say this
as a physician to come to my office or my place
because oftentimes it's too late and you cannot
treat a dead person the bite Administration has
not rejected the controversial idea of expanding
safe injection sites where people can legally use
drugs legislation remains tied up in courts
the Administration has openly pushed for drug
treatment programs inside prisons but it's
also not changed the standing of gupta's job
for the past 13 years the drug czar has not
been given the clout to speak regularly with the
president or sit at cabinet meetings President
Obama demoted this position from cabinet level
are you hoping that your boss right now
re-elevates it to cabinet level I come to work
every day and I focus on everything that I can do
every single day to help Americans out there make
sure that they're doing they're living longer
they're being able to have safer and healthier
communities as such and that's where my focus
remains is that a yes or a no well I'm going to
continue to do what the American people want us to
do with just to make sure that we're working hard
to end the opiate crisis and I'm going to keep
doing that lately there has been some better news
new data released this week shows overdose deaths
that surge during the pandemic have declined
slightly for five straight months we certainly
feel confident that there seems to be a light at
the end of the tunnel meaning that we've now seen
about two and a quarter percent reduction from
from the peak of Overdose deaths that's about 2500
people but think about it like a large ship you
you can't just turn it around you've got to slow
down and then it takes time to turn that around
the question is whether that dip becomes
a long-term Trend or whether it's just a
temporary thing but overdose is now the leading
cause of death for Americans age 18 to 45. wow
I think one of the most interesting things
that he said to me is the idea that you got
to meet people where they are that there are
all of these problems what can you do in the
here and now and part of that is meeting them
where they are to try to solve the problem here
not just worry of the others as he said as
a doctor I can't treat a dead person wow and
then if there's this like understanding within
those users and many of us know people who use
even things like marijuana they think it's safe
and with these new um fentanyl being manufactured
in certain drugs that people thought at one
time were safe hey it's it's it's it's it's a
wide open Horizon a lot of this is just fentanyl
being used by itself but it it does happen yeah